Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P, here's something kind of funny.
So we launched The David Pakman Show Finance
Channel and I've mentioned this before. You
can find it at YouTube.com, slash, pacman,
finance. It's no politics. It's just basic
personal finance, education and advice. And
it's not specific advice. It's just general
concepts that are important to understand.
We're already almost at 10,000 subscribers.
It is seems to be striking a nerve. Last week
I showed a message from a viewer who said,
what are my credentials to even talk about this?
And I said, Well, I have an MBA specializing
in financial planning. Those are my credentials.
And it's not like a humblebrag. It's just someone
said, What are your credentials? Those are my
credentials. And here is a caller who says, No,
no, no, no, no, that's not enough.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. You know,
I recently watched your video on your main
YouTube channel talking about, you know,
how exactly you're qualified to talk and
matters. And you said because you had an MBA,
you're qualified to talk on financial matters.
Well, David, let me get something straight here.
An MBA does not make you qualified to talk
on financial matters. Okay. Come back when
you're on a ski or something really special.
Okay, David, I've been freaking gripped in
this because you have an MBA. Doesn't mean you're
qualified to speak on financial matters. In fact,
I think the most prudent financial advice comes
from Dave Ramsey. David. You know, Dave Ramsey has
not an MBA that.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Well,
Dave Ramsey does have a bachelors degree, so that
is something. Yeah, listen. To be totally honest.
There's people who know a ton about personal
finance and don't have any degree in it. It's
actually it was sort of like a joke. It reminds
me of some discussion we were looking at where
someone said to an economist, what qualifies you
to give economic analysis anyway? And the guy's
like, Well, I have a PhD in economics. It's you
know, we've talked about the appeal to authority
and the appeal to expertize is potential cognitive
biases or logical fallacies, rather not cognitive
biases. And the truth is, I don't even really
subscribe to what I said, which is like,
I know about this stuff because of my degree,
because quite frankly, most of the stuff you learn
by doing and you learn by individual research
and learning. But anyway, I encourage you.
Check out the Finance Channel. Subscribe for free.
Totally different thing. The way I describe it is
it's like Dave Ramsey without the right wing
nut tree, without the Christian messaging
and without the anti-vax. That's the idea of the
Pacman Finance Channel, YouTube.com slash Pacman
finance. We've got a great bonus show
for you today. Joe Biden is warning oil
industry companies as Hurricane Ian has made
landfall in Florida. And Joe Biden is saying,
do not gouge the American people on gas. We will
see if they will heed his warning. Joe Biden has
also approved an additional billion plus dollars
in security assistance to Ukraine. Are Republicans
in favor of or against this? Because remember, it
was Biden didn't do enough for Ukraine. And also
there's too much money going there. Wait. So how
could it be both? And Donald Trump is seeking to
end his rape accusers defamation lawsuit. Is
this finally going to be the end of the road
for that lawsuit or not? All of those stories
and more on today's bonus show. Sign up at join
Pacman dot com. Use the coupon code in date to
get yourself a discount and we will see you then
when I am joined by producer Pat, by the way. A
lot of people writing in and saying, David, what
is up with that bruise on producer Pat's nose?
He explains it on the bonus show this week. He
explains what happened to his note. So please tune
in, join PACOM. We'll see you on the phone. Check.